Speaker 1: We've been wondering.
Who came up with the idea of just say you
won after the 20 20 election, Trump going
out, remember, about two to 30 in the morning,
there was no reason to think that Trump was
going to be the next president of the United
States at the time.
We certainly didn't know at that point.
And Trump said, we won.
We won.
We now have a very specific new report about
this.
This is in The Guardian, which says A drunken
Rudy Giuliani urged Donald Trump on election
night to just say we won.
As key states started to slip away from Trump,
Rudy repeatedly urged the former president
to lie.
According to a new book, a drunken Rudy Giuliani
report repeatedly urged Donald Trump to just
say, we won on election night in an election
night last November, according to a new book,
even as key states started to slip away from
Trump and defeat by Joe Biden, Drew near the
former mayor of New York, was then acting
as Trump's personal attorney, a role in which
he had fueled Trump's first impeachment and
would later lead hapless attempts to prove
Trump's lie that his defeat was the result
of electoral fraud.
According to Carol Leonnig and Philip Rucker
of The Washington Post, both very good reporters,
authors of the forthcoming book I Alone Can
Fix It. Giuliani approached senior Trump aides
early on election night at the White House.
What's happening in Michigan?
He asked the campaign manager, Bill Stepien,
chief of Staff Mark Meadows and senior adviser
Jason Miller told him it's too early to know.
Giuliani said, just say we want.
The aide said it was the same in Pennsylvania.
Just say we won Giuliani's grand plan.
The authors report was to just say Trump won
state after state based on nothing.
Stepien, Miller and Meadow's thought this
argument was both incoherent and irresponsible.
Hilariously, they later jumped right on board
with that.
Meadow's reportedly responded angrily.
We can't do that.
We can't.
But Trump did.
Just go declare victory right now, Giuliani
reportedly told the furious Trump, you've
got to go declare victory now.
And as we know, at 2:00 a.m., Trump walked
into the East Room.
This is a fraud on the American public.
He said this is an embarrassment to our country.
We were getting ready to win this election.
Frankly, we did win this election.
We did win this election.
Speaker 6: Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
Speaker 1: Trump's words gave a title to another
author in the crowded field of Trump based
reporting, Michael Bender.
His book is called Frankly, We Did Win the
Election.
And a third by Michael Wolff landslide provide
similar accounts of Giuliani's behavior and
inebriation at key moments.
Guys, it can't get any more clear than this.
This was something even Rudy Giuliani knew
was a fraud all along.
They later apparently felt, you know, once
you're once you step into the pool, you're
swimming in it.
And then the hearing started and the lawsuits
and the press conferences and everything else.
But according to the reports on election night,
even people who later acquiesced to these
delusions that Trump won seemed to be against
them.
And so I think we're going to continue getting
more and more information like this as we
go, but no surprise in anything that is contained
here.
So I don't typically read these types of books
because I've so much stuff, stacks of stacks
and massive dumps of books to read.
But some of these new ones I actually am pretty
curious about.